[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
my tongue actually a little bit a while
ago so it's okay
uh and it hurt and it stayed hurting for
a bit and it didn't turn into a canker
store
canker store wow worst store of all time
i'm gonna go shopping at the canker
store canker sore uh didn't turn into a
[ __ ] canker sore or
as some old women would call it a canker
which is so [ __ ] disgusting for some
reason i don't know how you leave out
the word soren it becomes more
disgusting did you get a canker
[Laughter]
anyway dude uh i'm on tour i'm on tour
chrisalia.com we got dallas atlanta
washington dc wichita
um uh and savannah georgia and um
raleigh north carolina we've got a bunch
of ones coming up boston
uh peoria
rockford illinois look at this just
lakeland florida for some reason we're
going there
jacksonville florida for some reason so
go to chrislea.com dallas is the first
one up dallas in wichita what wichita
so uh
let's uh let's have a good time there
dallas and wichita and atlanta and uh
washington dc but um yeah so that's that
and go get your [ __ ] summer apparel
at crystalia.com life rips i was where
i'm wearing the life rip socks right now
actually and something happened first of
all these are my favorite socks now do i
have feeder flippers
i've got big-ass feet can't push me over
um
and i've been wearing these uh socks and
i love these socks these my favorite
socks i wear all the time
really nice fit really nice you know
they breathe it's just really
ridiculously nice chrisley.com and um
they're the most slippery socks of all
time i don't know if that's my floor or
what but i keep [ __ ] slipping dude
i'm like a cartoon in these [ __ ]
socks i'm just walking down the stairs
and it'll go
whoa whoa
that's the life rips commercial so uh
yeah man
uh
that's that um join our super clips uh
channel
uh and uh and you know and rate and
review and [ __ ] all the [ __ ] whatever
dude but you know what it's fine this is
congratulations and we're still kicking
ain't we we're having a good time dude
slip real hard bit my lip it's all good
man slip real hard bit my tongue it's
all good man
no pain no gain you know as they say
that's that's um i don't know if i agree
with that but whatever dude um
been out today having a good time woke
up late all good woke up 11 all good
dude
okay
woke up 11. woke up at 11. calvin woke
up at [ __ ] 11 20. how's it happen
dude i don't know you know here's what
happened
kristen was nauseous last night she went
to bed early and your boy me and my boy
calvin uh was just hanging out we were
watching tv and you wanted to watch what
did you want to watch i forget what he
wanted to watch but we were just playing
having a good time and then i brought
him to bed by myself and dude it was so
nice man we were just chilling having a
good time and i was just like watching
him and he was in the bed and he was
laughing and we were just having a good
time dude being a parent is the [ __ ]
absolute best a lot of you guys reach
out too and you say oh dude i didn't
want to be a parent till i heard you
talking about calvin and i hope you get
a [ __ ] calvin man
because you know
that's uh that's a special one you know
i don't know what the [ __ ] the boy the
boy slept till 11 20. i slept till 11 he
slept until 11 20. he's just like i'll
just wake up whenever you do 20 minutes
after after you die
so that's what's up um and we took him
to the doctor today and uh because he
had his checkup and he's two and a half
but he talks like a three-year-old
that's what she said she was asking him
questions like it was an interview and
he was answering them dude
she was just like what are you doing she
said what do you do the doctor said what
do you do when you uh when you uh what
do you do when you walk what does she
say what do you do when you
what do you do when you're oh yeah what
do you do when you're hungry and he's a
i eat food and she was like what do you
do when you um
when you're tired i get my pillow and
she said what do you do when you get
when you get cold and he says go in the
pool and and she was like oh i don't
know if that's right i was like it
actually is we keep a pool [ __ ] 100
degrees because kristen likes a big
[ __ ] jacuzzi dude
oh yeah she likes a big jacuzzi i like
it a little bit cooler but it's all good
man she does what she wants dude
happy wife happy life but resentment
sets in bro just kidding dude just
kidding these are jokes dude
right these are jokes because the
internet will [ __ ] tear me apart oh
look at him dude look at him man see
dark chris just came out nah dude
um we chillin man we're chilling dude
we're having a good time i'm just
[ __ ] i'm happy
i'm doing my shows everything's good
hell yeah dude let's drop you know what
[ __ ] for good measure dude
[Music]
i'm gonna watch that [ __ ] mayor of
kingstown i heard it's good i heard it's
about a fixer dude every now and then
they'll make a show about a fixer and
that [ __ ] pops off and remember ray
donovan do it and then they made a movie
about ray donovan i don't like when they
do that by the way when they make a tv
show and it's like five seasons and then
all of a sudden they're like hey let's
make a movie though
you gotta wait like 30 years to do that
and then make it a comedy like they did
with starsky and hutch
you can't just all of a sudden make a
[ __ ] move i guess you can but like
who the [ __ ] gonna go see it like they
made that entourage movie did they make
an entourage movie after entourage
[ __ ] gonna go you know
i mean fine but like did you did it make
money i don't know dude mark wahlberg
makes so much [ __ ] money it's
ridiculous the guy's just so [ __ ]
lonely you know he's got a full family
and he's just always like on a boat with
his municipal pink shirt on
[Laughter]
you know you got to keep dreaming right
you got to trust in the lord jesus
christ don't you
that's the thing about trusting in the
lord jesus christ he always got
everything he's always got you back you
know
i love it i love it i love
i love religion dude i'm religious
i'm religious man i'm all of them i'm
christian i'm jewish i'm [ __ ] hindi
oh dude you know what i am now for real
i tell you what actually and let me tell
you this
this is the most beautiful [ __ ] of all
time i have now not been doing movies
i've had some offers and i i turn them
down cause i don't want to you know i
just don't want to i don't want to [ __ ]
with it i just i i'm happy doing stand
up i'm happy doing my podcast i'm happy
being a dad i don't want to go to
[ __ ] you know what i mean like
portland maine for a month and a half to
shoot a movie with [ __ ] somebody in
it that's like
you know the second lead of a tv show
that's popular and then it like comes
out somewhere
right it's on like cinequest like it's a
it comes out like world premiere at
cinequest film festival and you're like
where the [ __ ] is that you look it up at
san jose and you're like oh that's a
waste of my life dude yeah but it's for
the yard but is it really though dude
because everyone's just trying to sell
tissues that's what's trying to really
is it really though
or is it are you really just trying to
push [ __ ]
everybody's always trying to [ __ ]
sell something and i guess i am too baby
but welcome to capitalism hey
welcome to capitalism hey
um
well the fact that i'm somebody that
said welcome to capitalism makes me want
to [ __ ] shut the door on my fingers
but um
i was talking about uh
you know and i you know i don't know if
if i'll ever you know do
i was like ah [ __ ] what do i want to
do i want to [ __ ] act and [ __ ] you
know because sometimes i'll see a movie
i'll be like maybe i'll write something
maybe i'll be in something maybe i'll
[ __ ]
crowdfund something or maybe i'll you
know what i mean they will try to get
back in the game and it's like i see
myself there at some point obviously of
course i can do it but also i'm like why
though man what do i want because like
dude when i was like really like trying
to get work as an actor i'm like i never
had i almost almost not all the time and
i made some great relationships and some
great friends and [ __ ] but i didn't
always have
i i was like most of the time it was
just not fun man you're waiting around
in a [ __ ] argyle sweater playing some
dork and you're just like at craft
service eating [ __ ] jujubes for some
reason and you never eat this [ __ ] you
gotta bagel and jujubes and you're just
sitting there and you're like can i get
some club soda and they never bring it
and you're like all right man i'm
comfortable at home though
i make more money on the road what am i
doing this for so my profile gets bigger
who cares i don't want to be more famous
so like i'm like i don't know but i'll
tell you what i do want to do
and this is absolutely the [ __ ] truth
and i sat and i told this to kristen and
she rolled her eyes and that's how i
know it's gold baby
i'm not getting back into hollywood
i'm getting into bollywood
are you kidding me dude
have you seen bollywood
you seen it
dude
you seen it
i know indians have seen it and asians
have seen it but whites
blacks
you seen it
oh dude there's barely any scenes where
both
feet
of the main character are on the ground
together
they're either dancing or kicking or
jumping on dudes [ __ ] yeah dude that's
what i want and i swear to god
85 of the time they're [ __ ] smiling
and 15 of the time they're crying do it
and that is the kind of movie i want to
be it's a [ __ ] soap opera that is
also the matrix dude i
it is my life's goal to be in a [ __ ]
bollywood movie dude i watch this movie
rrr on
uh on netflix it's called rr i don't
even know what it stands for it doesn't
matter dude and i watch the movie like
this
oh my god dude the first scene i'm in
the first scene
i'm in and let me tell you why dude
the main first of all i don't even know
if it's in you could
ask me
when you see me
hey was that movie in english or not
i don't know and i saw the whole thing
got no clue
[Music]
dude no clue
zero clue if it was in english or not i
think maybe it was but also i'm pretty
sure it wasn't dude
and if it wasn't english it was
they did the weirdest [ __ ] thing with
like dub over a dude that's already
speaking english with another dude that
speaks english i guess better
it just sounds like it's a children's
show but the guy will be like we need to
get our warriors and go and the [ __ ]
guys the line is like we need to get our
warriors and and spread out on the field
and the [ __ ] way it sounds is we need
to get our warriors and set out on the
field
and then so the first scene is dude it
opens up this movie rrr opens up dude
and the guy's like
there's a mob there's an angry mob is
this on netflix and there's an angry mob
trying to get into this fortress i don't
know what it is dude i don't even know
you know they're just trying to get into
a fortress and i'm like okay i'm
watching and i'm just involved with it
okay
i turn it on just cuz right
um and so i play it and then and then it
starts and then they're like there's a
mob and they're trying to get into the
fortress and
the general is like we better hold you
know we better [ __ ] we better keep
our eyes on and there's aren't there's
army [ __ ] guys soldiers on the inside
of the thing
they're just waiting for in order and
then somebody
in the mob takes a [ __ ] like
a rock or it's not a rock it's like a
clump of dirt and throws it and it hits
something on the inside of the fortress
and the and the leader guy sees it and
he says get him or something and one
guy's
feet
one
soldier's feet leaves the ground dude
and he jumps over the fence like a human
can do it can't but this is bollywood
[Music]
leaps over the fence and
the guy is [ __ ] four football fields
away and he just fights the whole mob
the whole mob chokes people out breaks
her arms
[Laughter]
and gets to the guy and carries him back
and then leaps over the thing and then
just there's [ __ ] 40 000 people just
takes on 40 000 people not like 10 guys
[ __ ] john wick dude this guy takes on
40 000 indians and he does it
and this is the best part about [ __ ]
bollywood
this is the best
part about bollywood is
these guys are superheroes
but they make zero mention of any super
powers and that's the kind of [ __ ]
movie that i'm into dude they do not
they do not have
they don't have like the scene where
they're like well with this power we
wield like dude it's it's it's none of
that [ __ ] it's just some guy who will be
talking to a chick and then all of a
sudden
jump off the back of a horse and his
feet
never touched the ground for 33 more
minutes dude and the song's just all
like
and he just kicks [ __ ] indian
[ __ ] in
[Music]
just
oh dude and i never know which guy is
which guy because i'm racist i guess
dude it is so ill though bollywood is
where it's at and if i'm not in
bollywood before i take my last
breath i have failed okay
i want to go to india and be in it i
don't care what part
india
your boys for higher and i'll take
[ __ ] less rupals or whatever kind of
[ __ ] money you guys have
you know what i'm talking about
forget it man
i love it dude oh dude and they s oh oh
and if that's not enough
they also sing
[Music]
they had to go ahead and make it my
favorite oh
hey
[Music]
it's also a musical
hey
sorry to interrupt you sir
yes
it's also a musical
what
dude and they dance dude and they do the
kind of dancing where the like the i
don't know how to describe it but they
do like did they twist the feet like
this and they're always smiling dude i
mean dude and they fight tiger it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable if you
have a problem
and
in flight and like a [ __ ] the landing
mechanism can't work and the wheel can't
go down you get a bollywood actor to fly
up there and [ __ ] push the wheel down
and let the plane land on him bollywood
can do that man i don't know why they
don't make it and then i realize
you know for some reason
the bollywood [ __ ] is way better like
it's basically like the only other
people who make movies like this are
um
like asians make moves i mean you know
it's asian but asians make movies like
this but it's a little bit more like
this is badass and not funny right like
asians will make movies whether japanese
are korean and it's like okay they're
not really superheroes but they're
[ __ ]
um there's no humor about it and the the
bollywood [ __ ] just rides the line of is
this humorous or not but it's still kind
of badass but these guys are having such
legit fun when they're doing that
and there's dances there's dance-offs in
it so basically there's the asians that
make it too and then there's like the
fast and furious movies from america and
they just are not as good for some
reason and i think it's because there's
no humor in it you know it's just like
we're family and like you gotta believe
that and be a dumb [ __ ] guy in the
theater and be like dude you know what
it actually really is about family
though i mean i know this movie like the
cars are flying from one building to
another and yeah it's not realistic
because one [ __ ] dodge viper just
jumped onto a [ __ ] crane and swung
into a hotel but honestly
it really though is about family if you
read between the lines
and you don't have to read between the
lines because vin diesel is saying that
too
the diesel's fat um so um yeah dude
just kicking [ __ ]
indian
[ __ ]
in
i want to be in it there's [ __ ] oh
man
the white dudes in the [ __ ] bollywood
movies are bad guys too
just bad guys they have like one they
have one guy that i kind of recognize he
was probably in a james bond movie and
[ __ ] and he was just like the worst guy
of all time he literally like took a
[ __ ] uh
uh
branch tree branch and [ __ ] smacked
it into like a uh
a child and [ __ ]
look it's just really violent man but
man do they dance their [ __ ] asses
off and i'm in [ __ ] bollywood now i
guess so all good man bollywood
i swear to god if i'm not in a bollywood
movie just know i failed before i take
my last breath if i'm not in a bollywood
movie i felt
i'll wear whatever you want me to i
don't give a [ __ ]
uh yeah so
i can't believe this movie
there's the one guy i started following
it on instagram though
this guy he's like the [ __ ] um indian
chuck norris
uh what is it
uh
hold on where the [ __ ] is it here we go
here we go here we go
uh aj devon dev dev
say it um too many consonants in a row
um more the only [ __ ] more conscious
in a row is a movie rrr um so yeah gotta
do it
you know how like people say like
protect
[ __ ] yadda yadda at all costs or
whatever that's a thing you know like we
must protect cat protect cat williams at
all costs because he said something
about [ __ ]
suge knight
or tupac you know
this uh
whatever the opposite is
do that to matthew mcconaughey
you know what i mean
like
look the guy's a phenomenal can be a
phenomenal actor okay let's say that can
be a phenomenal actor like no hate on
the matthew mcconaughey shits now let's
get into some comedy because they would
be like dude dude i did the [ __ ] i
posted my my clip about making fun of
jay-z it's like it's so stupid it's just
a silly [ __ ] rap lyric bit that i i
literally went on stage and they were
playing jz so i started talking about it
and people were like bro don't
disrespect the [ __ ] i'm all right
dude you know it's like
okay all right
cool i won't disrespect hov
okay cool yo dude not cool not cool to
disrespect one of the gr
you know
hanging into liking dudes no way
don't call me gay
it's all good but i'm not
whatever the opposite of the protect
yada yada at all costs is of matthew did
you know our national bird the bald
eagle
its primary purpose in life is to build
a better
nest
i don't know why but i like that
uh i thought he said something
so
[ __ ]
show-stopping
thought he said something so
[ __ ]
groundbreaking
thought he said something
so
[ __ ]
jaw-dropping thought he said something
so
[ __ ] pants [ __ ]
did you know our
potential the potential of it the
potential of it like the potential of it
is the potential scale
is to build a better
net potential skill potential skill
i don't know why but i like that
oh potential scale [ __ ] absolutely
destroyed when it said nothing
[Music]
i don't know
why is he sitting in grass taller than
him dude he's sitting in a [ __ ]
drinking this is a commercial dude don't
be had
dude
staring at his bourbon
hey bro are you lex luthor
are you professor x
did you know our national bird the bald
eagle
its primary purpose in life is to build
a better nest
i don't know why but i like it
dude
the [ __ ] first
did you know i can't
you keep listening its primary purpose
in life is to build a better
nest
i don't know why but i lied
dude unbelievable man
unbelievable
this guy dude just
just [ __ ] eating his own [ __ ] you
know and just loving it come on over i
wouldn't be surprised if [ __ ] in a
year and a half honestly matthew kind of
has a huge event and he saved up all
like his x-men all year and he's just
like it's kind of a [ __ ] eating uh
[ __ ]
extravaganza everybody come on by
it's it's not even invite only you can
come i don't care just he might eat my
[ __ ] man i've been doing it for years
you just come in you just eat my [ __ ]
man right it doesn't even stink here
come in here look at this you gotta play
this [ __ ] right there and i don't know
why i don't like that you're taking a
drink eating it look dip your finger in
there
i don't know why but i like that i'm you
know i'm from texas
yeah longhorns man book em or whatever
the [ __ ] you know
buck em boys
baler or whatever the [ __ ]
hook them hook them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them random cowboys or
whatever the [ __ ] sayings are in
texas
why [ __ ] a dude when you could [ __ ]
ride a horse or whatever the [ __ ] it is
i don't know
why why barrel why [ __ ] it hey we
welcome to matthew khan hey [ __ ] eating
extravaganza
the guy just [ __ ] so you know what he
is dude oh wow i just realized he's
armenian
dude he is
he is
a hundred percent
armenian dude
this is so something a [ __ ] armenia
would do it's a
eat all your food or you'll have an ugly
wife dog
[Laughter]
hey do you know the hey do you know that
the national bird
[Laughter]
hey come here dog
where was it again hold on let me
where's the clip [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up god
damn it
a dog a
the dog it the national bird dog
did you know our national bird the bald
eagle oh its primary purpose in life is
to a dog a a b a for real though hey put
that down a hey dog the national bird
the bald eagle hey look at look at nema
hey the national bird enima come here
hey listen to me doug armand
the national ironman put that down hey
listen to me the national
[Laughter]
the national bird a the national bird
um
the bald eagle dog a nima and armin put
that down
is actually um
their main purpose is to build a better
nest
i like that bro
a
nema put that down dog
why is nemo always picking [ __ ] up dog
hey arman armand and nemo speaking [ __ ]
up dog
i mean [ __ ] you dude this is unreal man
matthew mcconaughey is so unreal dude
i don't know why but i like that dog
welcome to the [ __ ] eating
[Laughter]
welcome to the [ __ ] eating contest
welcome to the matthew mcconaughey
welcome to the armin and nema [ __ ]
eating extravaganza dog
wow
we love it
i gotta wait
here we go we gotta watch this other one
we gotta watch this other one that i had
on the [ __ ]
r2d2
i don't think that should ever gotta
stop we gotta keep that and we gotta
keep it weak
you know if
a sense of humor was the default emotion
not an emotion i think the world would
be a lot better place
it's evil
can't a tourette's dude tourette's dude
it is
not an emotion oh
god you know you know he just [ __ ]
was
just winking
dude how annoying would it be with him
you want to go out you want to go mile
out and just sit in some chairs and
stare at bourbon and i'll just talk to
you i'll say some really important [ __ ]
until it crumbles
what stop winking i don't know i just
think that you shouldn't ever go out of
style
okay
yeah and whistling too you know sense of
humor was a default emoji a dog
nema put that down a a if sense of humor
was the default a dog
[Laughter]
oh my god
imagine a guy whistling and winking all
the time
never go out
sir old-fashioned
um yeah so anyway
wow
uh
uh
god matthew saw the kind of guy that
would like buy a [ __ ] car that was so
old and come in and show his buddies and
be like hey guys i did a thing
[Laughter]
hey fellas i did a thing
i did a thang bought an old horse look
at that huh close to death about two
years ago we fed it and we raised it oh
boy i did a thing
um
so yeah
don't know what minecraft is we'll never
know what minecraft is
um how about this [ __ ] dude the [ __ ]
apps oh wait no this clip
this clip is so funny to me this and not
because of the reason it's funny because
of other reasons when trump said the
thing about
uh how he would be the best women's
basketball coaching nba
just listen this whole thing
and i'll tell you what if i were ever uh
i'd be the greatest
woman's basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better but
but i
i mean so dick for no reason but i'd go
up to lebron james it doesn't matter
did you ever have any desire to be a
woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody will come within 70 points of
this team
i mean so
[ __ ] all over the place this thing
i love how all over the place i'll tell
you what if i were ever uh i'd be the
greatest by the way has no idea what
he's saying what he's going to say at
the first second dude listen to this
and i'll tell you what if i were ever i
had no idea i'd be the greatest right
here that's what he
decided you know because i don't like
lebron james so dick for no reason dude
so dick for no reason just dragging
lebron into it for no reason
michael jordan much better okay so he
likes markers much better okay cool
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter so drunk dude it doesn't matter
ron did you ever have any desire to be a
woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody i mean dude just said it doesn't
like lebron james and now he's just
[ __ ] basically stroking him off
saying they [ __ ]
be the best player on every team
i don't like lebron i don't know like
you know i would be the best women's
[ __ ] basketball team i wouldn't want
i wouldn't
because i don't like lebron james i'm a
michael jordan guy so i would go up to
lebron james and i'd be like take us to
the championships hey what are you
saying it doesn't matter so drunk dude
when he does that part
basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better
but i
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter i say lebron why does he say it
it's like breathing it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't matter
so good dude so good it got
so good didn't mean to be that funny but
it was
i go to lebron james it doesn't matter i
don't like lebron james [ __ ] lebron
james i need him on my team
this is crazy this is i think maybe the
craziest thing that's happened so far
with this new
no i shouldn't say new just the woke
thing is so weird
so beyonce
has
uh
put in the song
spazzin out right that's what she said
spazzin out
um
oh wait so it happened to lizzo i guess
first i didn't know this but
um
after received backlash from disability
activists and organizations beyonce's
team confirmed that they will re-release
the song heated off her new album
renaissance removing an offensive
ableist term the track co-written by
drake
uses the derogatory term for [ __ ]
diplegia a form of cerebral palsy how
the [ __ ] is beyonce supposed to know
this [ __ ] or do you think drake knows
drake's making songs every three days he
has no [ __ ] idea what sp [ __ ] is
the word
not used intentionally in a harmful way
will be replaced a representative told
insider in a statement the lyric stop
spazzing on that ass spazz on that ass
was criticized
this is south park was criticized for
its use of derogatory language and we
can't help but wonder where beyonce's
team was when lizzo received the same
criticism for using the term
in girls when the song was first
released in june a viral
tweet by australian writer and
disability advocate see this is the
thing dude they don't have anything to
do like this like a disability advocate
this is what they're busying their time
with
explain the terms harvard use against
people like her with [ __ ] diplegia
this is what she said hey lizzo my
disability cerebral palsy is literally
classified as [ __ ]
diplesia where
spasticity the specif spasticity in our
city
[Applause]
refers to unending painful tightness in
my legs
your new song makes me pretty angry and
plus sad spazz doesn't mean freaked out
or crazy it's an ableist slur it's 2022
do better dude you really how the [ __ ]
like
the everything's changing
how are you supposed to keep up with it
so this is what beyonce should have done
well [ __ ] man
didn't mean to
and then sing all the single ladies or
whatever the [ __ ] you know
oh that was lizzo
whatever the [ __ ] lizzo sings
liz should have been like sorry and then
posed in a bikini or some [ __ ]
lizzo was quick to respond issuing an
apology and promising a re-issue of the
song removing the heart
lizzo says it's been brought to my
attention that there's a harmful word in
my new song girls spelled it with
you know
three r's
let me make one to clear i never want to
promote derogatory language as a fat
black woman in america i've had many
hurtful words against me so i overstate
stand the power words
intensely or in my case unintentionally
i'm proud to say there's a new version
of girls with a lyric change this is a
result of me listening and taking action
and as an influential artist i'm
dedicated to be a part of the change
i've been waiting to see in the world
it's just you know
make more ramps how about that
know
the energy
these words man
just over a month later beyonce's heated
is under similar fire dude i wish i was
[ __ ] huge i'd make a song called
spazzing out
spazzing out didn't mean it that way
in the parentheses spazzing out
parentheses didn't mean it that way
spazzing out in parentheses
just meant going riri
[Laughter]
whatever [ __ ] cancel me you know
gives a [ __ ]
uh just over a month uh so
when lizzo's oversight and response felt
too many like progress for more
inclusive vocabulary and probably music
beyonce's repeat mistake strikes a
painful chord for some
these [ __ ] uh
goddamn articles dude
these [ __ ] cuck-ass articles man
like nobody gives a [ __ ] about this
actually you know there's nine people
who give a [ __ ] about this
and they're just forget this is the
thing if they just
the fact that beyonce
changed it
is the only reason why people complain
like if you don't [ __ ]
the only reason why this cancer culture
or the [ __ ] woke [ __ ] works is if
they think
that if if if they think there is an
outcome
once there's no outcome they just go
okay well let's listen to other songs
that do this and we'll try and change
them like
also how is everyone how is any by the
way beyonce is on another planet
mentally dude she doesn't know what
[ __ ] milk costs you know and she
you're you're supposed to
the daily uh changing of words and
what's a slur and what's not she's
supposed to [ __ ]
know about this
she doesn't know what milk costs
she lives on [ __ ] pluto
like she should have been like oh [ __ ] i
didn't mean it that way
next
the [ __ ] people busy themselves with
it's insane dude
is that the one they think they she
faked her pregnancy right they think
that people conspiracy theorists thinks
that she's faked her pregnancy that's
beyonce right that's beyonce
that's beyonce be like you know she
figured president's pregnancy
people are [ __ ] insane on the
internet man people are absolutely
[ __ ] insane on the internet
just so [ __ ] insane
there's so many [ __ ] things on my
instagram that are like do people send
me this all the time like crystalia like
somebody hi i'm crystaly's assistant hi
i'm crystalia i love that you love it
you have no idea how much you mean to me
and it's like it's not me dude and
people are like is this you it's not me
i'm not on the internet i'm not on the
internet except for i post and then i'm
out dude there's [ __ ] so many people
pretending to be me
there's so many people pretending to
[ __ ] reach out to people and [ __ ]
hey dude you get [ __ ] fin ass dude
who was i talking to somebody uh was
doing this with uh was it morgan willin
they were pretending that they were him
and they uh
were uh trying to get
money and they gave morgan whalen is it
wayland wallin wallin trying to give him
get him money and they gave him money
or i'm sorry they gave this quote
unquote morgan wallin money and then
they had a meet and greet and she was
like hey what's up it's me i give you
all this money and morgan wallin was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's not him you got finessed
you got finessed
why the [ __ ] would morgan wallin want
need a thir
need a [ __ ] whatever it is 300
you got finessed off paypal
how and it sucks dude
dude there's [ __ ] somebody out there
that says i'm on [ __ ] only fans
trying to get somebody to make a
get a [ __ ] for like
20 30 000
you're getting finessed
it's not me
you're getting finessed
the [ __ ] think for two seconds why the
[ __ ] would i pay 20 30 g's for a [ __ ]
joe job you getting finessed
it's so it's [ __ ] everyone's
mental dude
it's mental these celebs i can certainly
say for me if it's not the blue check
mark on instagram messaging you back
that shit's not me okay i don't have a
[ __ ] only fans account i don't have
these [ __ ]
and even then i don't even reply on
[ __ ] instagram that much i said
thanks or some [ __ ] e don't get finessed
dude because people are out there
getting finessed
it's so [ __ ] insane bro
oh it's so [ __ ] insane
and it's sad
and then like people [ __ ]
you know
that's just [ __ ]
like oh god
sad whatever dude what's up with china
they're taking over the world china's
taking over the world talk about getting
finesse you've seen tick tocks [ __ ]
user agreement or whatever the [ __ ] it
is dude i saw that [ __ ] on rogan i
forget who the guest was was it theo i
can't remember but it was like the tick
tock service the [ __ ] um terms and
conditions
oh my god you read that [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
dude it's like and we reserve the right
to come through to your house and
[ __ ] put cameras up and see how you
make the tick tocks
and we leave the cameras on 24 7 and we
take one of your [ __ ] sons or
daughters
it's insane dude china is [ __ ] you
know what china's doing for real dude
i'm not even bullshitting
chinese people like this
[Applause]
dude that's chinese people right there
that's what china is doing right now
just like this
[Applause]
hell yeah dude
we taking over
oh
[Applause]
god what's this [ __ ] this thing
about the [ __ ]
oh man and this is the whole thing
everyone's insane
helen keller why is it tick-tock
conspiracy theory undermining her story
like
what dude why is this even an article
why is this even an article
like why is it happening and why is it
an article
you know i'm talking about
despite her record as a writer and
activist what may have begun as a joke
has gained traction because that's the
thing nothing is just a joke anymore how
insane is that i read a [ __ ] article
the other day it was like tick-tock
stars that are trying to do stand-up
comedy trying to be stand-up comedians
is going to be the new comedians and
it's like do you know how hard stand-up
is
you need more than a ring light
you need more than a ring light you
can't be 22 or 23 and good at stand up
you got no life experience
you only got a ring light
and then and but there's no jokes
anymore dude you make a joke of people
like well it's actually dude i did the
[ __ ] jay-z joke and i put it on
tick-tock it went [ __ ]
dummy viral because your boy happens to
catch flames
okay
but he goes dummy i know people see me
do [ __ ] like that and they're like
[ __ ] me so conceited like they don't
even know that's a joke dude
yeah your boy catches flames but also
he's got a heart of gold dude come on
it's a joke the whole thing's a joke
just relax you
i know know man
despite her record as a writer and make
us ask questions
so uh what
what may have begun as a joke has gained
traction and should make us ask
questions that go beyond the cruel cred
credulity of gen z huh there's an
oxymoron uh when the internet is riddled
with conspiracy conspiracy theories it
can be difficult to decide which to
worry about
well q and on and pizzagate are proving
themselves to have radicalizing
potential with the real world
repercussions other are
others are flourishing beneath the radar
or certainly going unnoticed by anyone
over the age of 25.
okay
um what i mean to say is teenagers on
tick knock doubt the
existence of helen keller
this is irresponsible
some people on tick tock doubt the
existence of color
how could keller's existence be up for
debate
there is an ex extant there is extant
film footage what is extant film footage
of that's a short ass word i should know
what it is
uh activist and disability rights
advocate who became deafblind after a
childhood illness learned to communicate
using hand gestures and understanding
others through the tedoma method
whatever that is this is from the
guardian
um
she wrote 12 books more essays and
lectures
uh nobody gives a [ __ ] who came across
this conspiracy theory when speaking to
his teenage neighbors and nieces
said they and other proponents don't
doubt the existence of hel keller the
woman but the fact that she was both
deaf and blind
yet still able to write books jesus
christ dude you know
that's like a [ __ ] homer simpson joke
how did you write a book if she's deaf
and blind
she [ __ ]
mumbled it out
tapped somebody on what words to write
just this whole article dude
whatever dude until society as a whole
takes a more nuanced attitude to
disability prejudices such as these will
continue to exist all we can do now is
have a conversation with the teenagers
in our lives about color and ableism and
man a lot of ableist stuff going on dude
um
gotta [ __ ] uh no let's not undermine
uh helen keller huh let's not do that
she she probably exists okay and even if
she didn't do it just chill you don't
need to make a [ __ ] tick tock don't
get out your ring light
what helen keller deaf and blind and she
wrote a book get the ring light let's go
take your shirt off get the ring light
just end the [ __ ] thing
i hate the pointy tick knock ones dude
you know soccer mom 808
i like things i like cupcakes
[ __ ] pies picking up kids from school
getting railed in an alleyway
wait for it it says wait for it [ __ ]
wait for it dude these videos are eight
seconds you ain't waiting for [ __ ] dude
wait for it is like if you're gonna
watch the movie rr it's three hours and
seven minutes
that whole [ __ ] thing on the bottom
should say wait for it
it's [ __ ] three hours at seven dude
imagine making a movie three hours and
seven minutes long that's so [ __ ]
shitty to do to somebody i'm in
bollywood though
two
can't wait man
[ __ ]
chris bollywood is in bollywood
he dances and kicks ass and his feet are
only on the ground 85 of the time
i mean 15 whoops i backwards did up but
it's all good
uh are these real [ __ ] uh dessert
scales that you just put up
uh here's his i'm come out oh this is
she got [ __ ] roasted for this roasted
and toasted for this dude she got
roasted good afternoon i want to welcome
these leaders for coming in to have this
very important discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our
time um
i am kandala harris my pronouns are she
and her i am a woman sitting at the
table wearing a blue suit
and
undermined it
describe too many things after it dude
knows it's [ __ ] described too many
things after it my name is
kamala harris and my pronouns are she
and her i am a woman sitting at the
table
in front of a desk with a lamp behind it
there is a flag on the other side behind
me the table is glass and i am wearing a
blue suit and have shoulder-length hair
that's violence
dude that's [ __ ] violence to the
trans community dude you can't do that
[ __ ]
just use your pronouns and that's it
just use your also you don't need to we
know you know we know by now hey you're
the [ __ ] vice president we know by
now
here she her
i want to do that
i am crystalia i am sitting here behind
a desk from ikea
and my pronouns are
he she he her what just confuse the [ __ ]
out of people
him hi what
my pronouns are only him never say
anything else even
he or his or anything just him
you can't say
his pants you have to say him pants
caveman talk please thank you very much
now let's get down to the bottom of it
my
oh [ __ ] hi i'm krista lee i'm sitting at
a table that we
tried to make fit in this room it's too
it's too small of a room and the table's
too big
but that's this studio
my pronouns are corn
porsche
um that's the one joke that everyone
uses for trans people whatever dude i
don't want any violence against trans
people let me just [ __ ] tell people
that i love
i love [ __ ] dude i love them
all
be what you want
think think who you are i don't care man
i don't give a [ __ ] do it have a parade
do bollywood do it all wow she got
roasted and toasted for that though huh
unreal
i guess that's [ __ ] it man i mean
it's been an hour a little bit let's do
a little bit of this [ __ ] i love oh the
tinder stuff are these good
okay tinder let's do the tinder uh
[ __ ] the reddit right
on tinder okay yes here we go can't wait
somebody writes guys this is not
attractive okay what are they right
okay i don't want to sign in i don't
have a [ __ ] account please just bring
it up dude wow i don't see this is so
funny i don't see the image yet
oh it's not safe for work i guess i
gotta see it listen for it but but the
first comment under it is comes in two
minutes you know
here's this daisies or roses
and then next some flowers and then he
writes good now i know what to bring to
the funeral when i murder that
you know the
last word
oh dude i mean also he's got a blue
check mark does that mean he's famous
is this [ __ ] it says josh dude is
this josh the guy who played the bad guy
in the hulk what's his name what's his
name josh uh
[ __ ]
i don't know who gives a
josh lucas wow dude what about josh
lucas
well i'm gonna murder that
you know what i'm you know what i'm
gonna murder dogs look like children
here's another one oh my god do you have
a kid no why second photo second one for
me is on a mount i'm just so
already
not communicating right this is the this
is the [ __ ] relationship from hell
immediately i would have checked out
okay
oh my god do you have a kid know why
second photo second one for me is me on
a mountain are you dumb can you not
count he says that's literally my second
photo for me she says well soundly you
use logic that everyone starts from the
left and counts right
oh well you should
i don't know well you should use logic
and he says well if i went right to left
it'll be a picture of a cross on a
mountain and left to right a selfie of
me hiking on a mountain
and she said whatever the photo of you
holding something and he said that's a
dog there's more
that's a dog she says
hold on that's a dog and there's more
hold on me
oh the picture
is
clearly a dog
that was like when i was driving in the
car with my friend once and he was in
the passenger seat and he goes oh that
check's hot and i slowed down and it was
just a guy
like not uh not questionable a guy with
a ball cap on and a kind of a beard
that chick's hot i slowed down it was
just
gym
oh man check these as soon as i click on
them alright third one um
all right here we go another one dude
be trying to have a fun light-hearted
conversation
what's the best gatorade flavor he says
she says whatever flavor you choose to
spit in my mouth darling
oh
oh that's a dude that's from a guy named
steve of course it is man i thought that
the chick was saying that at first i was
like jesus man your dad died early as
[ __ ]
what's the best gatorade flavor whatever
flip you choose to spit in my mouth
darling a bird um
so [ __ ] gross dude all like just from
zero to sixty
i love the ones that go from zero to
sixty in one message
hey
what do you do on your day off
suck me beautiful
um what are you doing your day off want
to bury you oh
like the old [ __ ] aim
chat [ __ ] door closing
wow can't do it guy from police academy
um
i don't like how i can't [ __ ] see the
actual image here we go you don't date
outside of your race but do you make out
outside of your race oh my god this lady
writes i hate black people
and then the guy writes
oh
and the guy
is asian
this is the most
confusing thing dude
and the the [ __ ] thing on the tinder
she says
it says bunny mama and puppy mama
single and monogamous i don't date
outside my race lovable and kind curvy
but i don't date obese men
jesus christ i like my men skinny i love
hiking and adventuring but sometimes i
do like to relax i'm a huge germophobe
but i'll i like i use tape paper towels
to turn off the sink after washing my
hands with something i mean this is a
[ __ ] what a headache already i hate
one word sentences and hate
abbreviations oh that's probably why i
just wrote oh afterwards
okay she has a mutt all right cool man
wow people are sad all good
um
let's see another one here
um
somebody just wow somebody just sends a
period
that's some gangster-ass [ __ ]
and then somebody the person writes the
other person writes hey i may or not be
going away for a while because i
allegedly did something so what i'm
saying is we should kick it asap
wow oh so the oh is this like the is
this like she said to period because you
gotta the girl has to write first
is that what this isn't that that with a
dating app like that's one of them right
i think anyway whatever
so she was like letting him like okay
you let him know you could write
well i hope that's a joke
um here we go at least he's giving 100
honesty
this is the message i mean i'll be
honest you have the nicest boobs i've
ever seen that's a hundred percent
honesty too
he said honest twice
i bought a new pair of khaki shorts in
the mail and tried them on yesterday and
i'm not joking i was like my dick was
too big for them they were seven inch in
seamed so they were a bit short but you
could easily see my bulge those
oh
oh those messages were back to back dude
this guy is stunting on him dude this is
unreal this guy goes could you guys be
honest your boobs best was ever seen
that's 100 honestly too also i bought a
new pair of khaki shorts and i hope this
message was a day later honestly i
bought a new pair of guys scores in the
mail i tried them on yesterday i'm not
joking like my dick was too big for them
they were seven inch in seams so they're
a bit short but you could easily see my
bulge and she didn't respond in the
middle of it which is so good
at least he was honest dude my
[ __ ] out here spitting honesty
dude
here's another one
does this ever work
he writes what's the difference between
a being a wasp
she says can eat wasps and he says you
want to [ __ ]
i wonder what
wonder if that was always going to be
what he responded with no matter what
probably right
can't eat a wasp you can't eat a bee
either can you
honey
then she writes this is taking an
unexpected turn
oh wow
well this is insane
okay
i mean it was only a 7 8 inseam but
honestly it was just too big i need to
get new khakis
who cares
is this a tick tock
what's this here
for i don't know about you guys fool but
it doesn't even feel like it's [ __ ]
summer dog like
i don't know like huh there's like not
even like huh there's like not even
nothing to do or nothing for
so if you're trying to get federer
whether it's a joke or not
iq
40.
full i don't even know
his [ __ ] summer dog like
i don't know like i don't know there's
like not even like huh there's like not
even nothing
there's not even like huh
saying hi to herself in a convo by
herself asking herself what's going on
love it hey guys that's it for this
episode on youtube if you want to see
the raw uncut uncensored version uh with
the extra time in it there's more than
just what you saw go to
patreon.comchrisdelia and we have other
stuff there too we got a little episode
i did with kristin a little while back
and we also that was like a week ago and
then also we have um
uh an extra episode a month on our
patreon we also do another thing called
review mode where i review certain
things and uh just behind the scenes
stuff we also have a discord that we
chat on every now and then uh it's fun
man go on over and check it out it's all
for six dollars a month and i really
appreciate uh all your patronic
subscribers or and even if you're just
watching
for free
appreciate it
[Music]